please welcome two-time Oscar winner
Hilary Swank
good evening as a film actor you've got
to figure out how to get the character
you're playing small enough to get
through the tiny lens yet big enough to
fill the largest screen the craft
consists of making the right choices the
art consists of not noticing the craft
here are this year's five nominees for
acting and a leading role Philip Seymour
Hoffman in Capote
Terrence Howard in hustle and floor
Heath Ledger in Brokeback Mountain
Joaquin Phoenix and walk the line
David's laughing in good night and good
luck
and the Oscar goes to Philip Seymour
Hoffman this is the first Academy Award
a nomination for Philip Seymour Hoffman
his big-screen break was in Boogie
Nights
during his 36 days filming Capote even
in between shots and during breaks
Hoffman tried to stay in character
vocally and physically
even now um wow I'm in a category of
some great great great actors uh
fantastic actors and and I'm overwhelmed
I'm really overwhelmed I'd like to thank
Bill Vince and Caroline Barron and Danny
rosette the film would have happened
without them I'd like to thank Sarah
Fargo I'd like to thank Sarah Murphy I'd
like to thank Emily's if my friends my
friends my friends I'd like to thank
Bennett Miller and Danny Futterman who I
love I love I love I love I love uh you
know the Van Morrison song I love I love
I love and it keeps repeating it like
that and um and I thank Tom Barnard and
Michael Barker thank you so much and a
my mom's name is Marilyn O'Connor and
she's here tonight and I'd like if you
see her tonight to congratulate her
because she brought up four kids alone
and and she deserves a congratulations
for that and
we're at the party my you know and she
took me to my first play and she stayed
up with me and watch the NCAA Final Four
and my passions her passions became my
passions and you know be proud mom's I'm
proud of you and we're here tonight and
mm-hmm it's so good thank you